[CLAPS]
[SUSPENSEFUL MUSIC]
Ooh!
Whoa!
Wow!
And perfect timing!
Helpsters!
Trick or treaters!
[LIGHT UPBEAT MUSIC]
Happy Halloween.
Happy Halloween, young robot.
Thank you, Helpsters.
You're welcome.
Happy Halloween.
Come back next year.
Bye.
Happy trails.
Goodbye!
Happy Halloween!
We did it, everybody.
Yeah, we did.
[UPBEAT MUSIC]
(SINGING) High fives
and handshakes.
What a difference a plan makes.
Had a big, spooky problem
at the start of the day.
Made a plan, and the problem
started melting away.
Hooray!
No matter how hard.
No matter how new.
No matter how tangled up
and tough to get through.
What a difference a plan makes.
High fives and handshakes.
Boo!
Oh, woo-ga-boo!
High fives and handshakes.